good evening everybody ladies and
gentlemen can everybody hear me yes good
great crowd welcome so that you know
you're in the right place this is the
first of three lectures the Earl and
lectures but on by the Santa Fe
Institute many of you I'm sure have been
to some of our public lectures we
usually put on one a month and to try to
bring some of the leading age latest
kind of science that is going on to the
public and once a year we put on these
Ullom lectures where we invite one of
our SFI community the scent of into
community to give a set of three
lectures in a little more depth and
explore a set of themes that we think
are compelling and of relevance again to
the general public and tonight's I think
is a particularly relevant one you saw
the title before a cooperative species
how we got to be both nasty and nice by
one of my favorite colleagues and bows
who might want to say a few words about
I first want to remind you those that
are not so familiar maybe that the the
whole raison d'etre of Santa Fe
Institute is to bring together scholars
from multiple disciplines and really
forge serious transdisciplinary kinds of
collaborative efforts addressing some of
the big questions both in terms of
science and the in terms of the problems
facing society and again I think this
set of lectures really fits that bill
splendidly Sam I've known Sam for the
years that I've been involved with the
Santa Fe Institute Sam came to the Santa
Fe Institute as a part of the faculty
really probably in about 2,000
and has been a resident faculty member
for those years and we share him with
the University of Siena Sam's work has
covered in a great breadth and in the
last years he has become one of the
leading researchers in this intriguing
and extraordinarily important subject of
the origins of altruism and its
implications for if you like the future
of humanity and is relevance to some of
the big problems see the big whoops can
everybody hear me is okay this lecture
this set of lectures and the work that
Sam has been involved in covers
everything from population genetics to
archaeology anthropology economics
thrown in with a little bit of
philosophy dynamical systems agent-based
modeling game theory ethnography even
doing experiments on behavior and throop
illogical kinds of experiments and those
will be I'm sure exemplified as in in
the lectures and Sam is very much a
quintessential SFI SFI are and in
bringing many of these things together
with an extraordinary group of
collaborators Sam's pedigree so to speak
is also extremely interesting and he's
he's a remarkable man I must say he he
got his degrees undergraduate degree at
Yale in 1960 his PhD in economics from
Harvard and went on the faculty at
Harvard was on the factory of Harvard
for a number of years and has the
marvelous distinction I must say which I
heard from tremendous respect for of
having been fired by Harvard
haha
pepper because and this you really
should clap go ahead because he refused
to sign a loyalty
so he spent the last part of his career
before retiring from it at the
University of Massachusetts in Amherst
there was a professor of economics and
that's when he took over during that
period the latter part of that period
around the year 2000 the economics
program at the Santa Fe Institute which
morphed into the behavioral sciences
program which he now directs at the
Institute and this work is very much
integral to that whole program Sam let
me just tell you just a few odds and
ends few anecdotes about Sam one is that
he went to school in India he went and
in fact he went to a real Indian School
he and his sisters with the only non
Indians in that school and the reason
for this incidentally for those that are
old enough to recognize it was because
his father was ambassador to India at
the time and his father was a major
figure during the Kennedy era and I'm
sure that had a big influence on the
kinds of work that Sam has done as an
academic he also won awards on 42
concert tours in a choir male choir in
the Soviet Union an awards for that so
he can maybe sing to us at some stage
he's a good baritone and he's taught in
remote areas of Nigeria he was an
adviser an economic adviser to Robert
Kennedy during Robert Kennedy's abortive
candidacy for the presidency he's been
an advisor to Nelson Mandela post
apartheid era and he's just done some
what can I say some marvelous things
both in science
and in terms of civic duty I got to know
Sam when I started to get engaged with
the Santa Fe Institute and we shared an
office and one of the things that begin
tonight's to go to the Santa Fe
Institute from Los Alamos once a week
sometimes twice a week and in what was
remarkable to me didn't matter what time
i went to that office Sam was always
there didn't matter if I went up at
seven thirty in the morning before going
up to Los Alamos Sam was there and if I
stayed to 6 30 or seven Sam was still
there one of the things i can't stand
about him is that he's workaholic and
this really great in me still does to
some extent and 11 sunday i was i was
preparing to leave to give a lecture the
next day on the East Coast and I
realized as early in the morning that I
had forgotten some crucial part that I
needed for the talk and this was about
730-8 and I got in my car and I
remembered I left it on the desk at the
Santa Fe Institute and I drove up there
and on the way up I thought ah the one
compensation I have is that same I will
beat sand to the office for once and I
drove into the parking lot of the Santa
Fe Institute no cars nothing absolutely
dead and I went into the building and I
went down to the office and god damn it
there was sad and to add insult to
injury Sam of course a biked up and
anyone that no I can barely walk out
and to add even more insult to injury
same as older than me not by much so the
subject of tonight's talk is a really
deep and fascinating one and I wanted to
and I started thinking about a little
bit and thinking of how deep it is
despite the fact that he's going to talk
a lot about I think evolutionary biology
and how it can be that if you have the
naive you that the fittest survive
survival of the fittest how is it that
some of us some of us turn out to be
loving and altruistic and so on it's a
major question that worried Darwin and I
decided I would turn to some of the deep
thinkers and some of the texts to see
who was thought about this and by those
I mean places like the Bible and
Shakespeare and the Talmud and so on and
I'm not going to give you a whole bunch
of quotes but what i know i thought i
would do given that I we want to move on
quickly is that the quotes i like best
actually came to my surprise in some way
from the Talmud and we're all familiar
with love thy neighbor as thyself or
some version of that and the version
that i like that is Talmudic is what is
hateful to you do not do to your fellow
that is the essence of the whole of law
the rest is commentary and I think
that's the loving side and I think
another version of that is the famous
one which many of you are very familiar
with from rabbi Hillel apparently who
said if I am NOT for myself the
dog-eat-dog side who will be for me but
if I'm not for others what am I and if
not now when and I think that somehow
sums up
the kind of dilemma that we all face on
a daily basis and we face as a society
and we face as a nation so with all that
said I want to turn you over to this
remarkable man her Sam balls and who
will expose chelate on many of these
themes before doing so I have two other
small things one is to thank penny
penland we're sitting here in the
audience who is supporting this lecture
she's been a marvelous contributor over
the years to the Institute in supporting
these lectures and may i shamelessly ask
anyone else in the audience that were
always open for further support of such
lectures or anything else and finally I
was asked to say that in the upcoming
schedule some of our lectures are not on
the canonical Wednesday night and you
should those that are attendees of the
monthly lectures please make note of
that that you should look carefully that
some of them one of them is on a tuesday
at once or thursday so with that said
with that business taken care of Sam I
very much look forward to your lectures
great thank you all for coming thank you
for your interest in in my work and in
these questions it will be discussing
thank you Jeff for your very generous
introduction I love the people of Santa
Fe I don't know if there's any other
city in the world in which you can get a
vast number of people like this to come
out to hear topics that are really hard
and I'm not going to lie to you these
are hard topics and I'm not going to
spare you some of the difficulty in
trying to understand them the the topic
is why do vast numbers of humans
cooperate with people they know only
remotely not even family members or kin
they do so sometimes under the
incentives of economic gain they
sometimes do it under coercive
circumstances
but there often is an element of
goodwill of generosity of solidarity
which motivates them to in this case do
a good job and work with the other
fellow in this beautiful Diego Rivera
fresco mural but before we get going how
many people here who are eligible to
vote our plan to vote in November okay
okay there's a few people who probably
not eligible but just just bear that in
mind this parenthesis that and that will
become relevant later now I want to talk
about at David Hume the Scottish
economist and philosopher better known
as philosopher who proposed the
following about designing our societies
and organizing our lives he said
political writers have established it as
a maxim that in contriving any system of
government every man ought to be
supposed to be a knave and to have no
other end in all of his actions than his
private interest by this interest we
must govern him and by an and by means
of it make him notwithstanding his
insatiable avarice and ambition
cooperate to the public good now this
view of was of course taken up in
economics and became extraordinarily
important primarily because of the work
of the gentleman you're now looking at
Adam Smith Adam Smith understood that it
was possible to perform something akin
to what a medieval alchemists would do
that is to transform base human motives
into valued social outcomes and his idea
about doing this developed in his famous
book The Wealth of Nations is what he
called the invisible hand which would
guide an economy of privately
self-seeking members to a good end it is
not from the benevolence of the butcher
the brewer and the Baker that we expect
our dinner but from their regard to
their own interest and this then became
a foundation not only of economics but
of political philosophy and the work of
people like Hobbes Locke and others some
proceeding
all of those preceding Adam Smith now I
call this the Constitution for knaves
perspective it now informs economic
policymaking around the world the
writing of constitutions other aspects
of designing societies like criminal
deterrence educational policies
management strategies and so on it has
become an incredibly powerful idea our
biologists have taken it up as well with
a slightly different perspective they've
embraced the idea of self-interest as a
disciplining metaphor for how biological
evolution might take place here's
Richard Dawkins like successful Chicago
gangsters our genes have survived in
some cases for millions of years in a
highly competitive world this entitles
us to expect certain qualities in our
genes a predominant quality to be
expected in a successful gene is
ruthless selfishness this gene
selfishness will usually give rise to
selfishness of individual behavior now
if genes are selfish how are the
seemingly generous moral and civic
minded things that we see around us all
the time to be explained do some of you
recognize that little guy in the top
corner do you remember him he was about
this tall and he was walking with Yau at
the opening of the of the Olympics he
was the guy who during the earthquake he
was a hall monitor and having pulled two
of his friends out of the rubble he ran
back into the collapsing building and
somebody asked him his name is Lynn how
somebody asked him why did you do that
he's 10 years old and he said because
I'm a hall monitor that's what we're
supposed to do now the other picture of
course you recognize the courageous and
one has to say altruistic fireman of the
people of the city of New York now
usually the way this dilemma which is we
appear to see selfish activities but we
know the genes should not be I'm so
sorry we appeared we see the altruistic
activities
genes must be selfish there is a way of
reconciling this famously put forth by
the american at editor and journalist
conscience is the inner voice that warns
us that somebody may be looking or in
slightly more academic forum by the by
the distinguished biologist richard
alexander essex morality human conduct
and the moral psyche are to be
understood only if societies are seen as
collections of individuals seeking their
own self-interest now I love this
picture of Lin hao because he seems to
be looking at this quote and saying I
what I wonder if that's why I went in
that building and that fireman who may
well be no longer with us probably was
not thinking that his picture was being
taken at the moment that he entered that
building and so we have a train wreck
between this idea that we do apparently
generous things because of self-interest
and our everyday observation of what it
looks to us like the people are doing
things because they have moral
commitments or they have some desire to
do the right thing you recognize this
picture also this was a very moving
picture to me because I've worked in
South Africa with the South African
trade union movement before apart date
actually starting in nineteen sixty one
and I had the privilege of then advising
first the trade unions and then
President Mandela these are the people
lined up to vote in the first democratic
election in South Africa it's a
wonderful image you can imagine how long
they waited like the people in this hall
they're not apparently very many knaves
amongst them because voting takes some
time in this case few hours probably
standing in the Sun apparently is quite
hot that day with obviously
statistically no chance whatsoever of
affecting the outcome so the very fact
that people will stand in line and vote
is kind of puzzling of course
didn't think about this because the
number of people allowed to vote in
England in the 1740s was sufficiently
small says it may be voting did count
there now this paradigm somebody may be
looking constitution for knaves is
mistaken we're all knaves sometimes
we're like other animals but humans
succeeded as a species because sometimes
some of us are not and I mean that quite
literally and I'll come to that back to
that in the fifth in the in these third
lecture I think we succeeded spread
around the world peopled the world all
parts of it because of the very
characteristics which we're here
discussing that is that we are not
acting only because somebody might be
looking we're acting for other reasons
now the evidence for this and how we
came to be this uniquely cooperative
species and why this matters for the
future is what I'll try to address
tonight tomorrow night and Thursday what
I'll do today is a little bit of deck
clearing I want to show that many
important forms of cooperation and the
ones which distinguish us from other
animals could not be the result of
self-interest with a long time horizon
or any other self interest based model
those models do not explain why we act
the way we do in the cooperative
situations some of which I've just
indicated and I'm about ready to tell
you more about which types of behavior
I'm talking about but having done this
the self-interest models don't work
that's the bad news the good news is is
there's extensive evidence from my
experiments but really from hundreds of
others that we have predispositions to
behave generously and to behave fairly
towards people way beyond our immediate
family and we're also happy to engage in
costly activities to punish those who
violate social norms itself of course an
altruistic act to uphold social order
and social decency that thing over there
you will recognize
some computer programs that comes up if
you use a bad word and when your emails
i used i had to disable that one but
this thing over here means that the
thing it's indicating is a hot topic and
I I was also going to have a hammer and
I was going to put a hammer up there
because i wanted to indicate the stuff
that i saw it was nailed down because a
lot of the stuff is controversial and
i'm giving you of course a rather brief
run-through of this but i think if it
doesn't have if it's not a hot topic
it's because i think it's nailed down
there are a lot of people would disagree
about this this is pretty
uncontroversial but not well known now
before we start we have to do you're
like in the word right we have to do
some stuff about words when i use the
word cooperation I mean participating
with others sorry with others in a
common project that yields mutual
benefits although not necessarily
benefits to the actor net of the cost
that he or she's undertaken altruism is
defined conventionally as behaviors
benefiting others at a cost to oneself
and what that means is that one would
have higher fitness or wealth or some
other value to end with one abandon the
behavior now let me come to the mother
Teresa problem people get confused about
this because mother Teresa helps the
poor help the poor in Calcutta and she
really got a kick out of it she loved
doing it and therefore are we to say
that mother Teresa was selfish no I
think not mother Teresa obviously was
helping others at a cost to herself she
could have been doing something else now
the problem here is we need a few extra
words because altruism is a description
of a behavior and its consequences for
others in oneself people are motivated
by their desires by their needs by what
economists call their preferences or
tastes or habits or moral commitments so
I want to introduce a couple of
additional
words the word preferences just means
the way you evaluate an outcome that
might result from your actions it's a
pro and con statement about whether you
like something or not would like it to
come about the word self-regarding
preferences means those preferences that
consider only the things the outcomes
that are going to happen to me that's my
stand-in for the word selfish I used
self-regarding because I want to define
it exactly it's acting taking account of
only the action what the action is going
to cause me and then of course we have
other regarding preferences those
include taking account of how your
action is going to affect somebody else
and these other regarding preferences
here of course they may motivate
altruistic behavior so we're
distinguishing between a behavior here
and the reasons for the behavior that is
the motives the psychological proximate
motives that may account for them now
what we have to understand is we observe
that people are acting like this a lot
of the time I'll show you why i think we
observe that and therefore we have to
ask why these kinds of preferences
desires needs and so on could if we
could become common among us now i want
to start with saying a bit more about
why humans are really such unique
animals we do this kind of thing we do
I'll just give you a list the list could
go on we engage with large numbers of
non-kin that's the crucial thing that
really distinguishes us from a lot of
other animals including social insects
we engage in joint production like the
barn raising we engage in warfare we do
co-insurance that is we share food on a
broad scale whether we're
hunter-gatherers in the southern africa
or whether we're modern citizens of a
welfare state we sustain social norms
we're willing actually to risk getting
beaten up sometimes to go to tell
somebody hey that's no way to treat
somebody else and we do that in other
ways which are costly to ourselves we
obey laws when we could get away with it
get away with transgressing them it's
some gain to ourselves
we share information we co-parent by
co-parenting I don't mean just in the
family but we people take care of other
people's kids very extensively either
informally or through modern a provision
of those services and of course we vote
now obviously I could go on but notice
these all have the character of these
these behaviors extend often to very
large numbers of non Kim now my first
task is to show you that the models that
seek to explain human cooperation as if
it was based solely on the on
self-interest those models fail a very
powerful and persuasive and correct
model called kin altruism says that we
will help relatives close genetic
relatives because they are likely with
high probability to bear our jeans and a
gene which predisposes us to do that
could spread that's absolutely correct
but of course that cannot explain why we
cooperate so extensively with people to
whom we are substantially unrelated and
that happens in experiments and in the
real world now just a little footnote
this actually can altruism maybe
surprisingly it doesn't even explain
what goes on within families very well
I'd be happy to talk about the the
details about that i published actually
some on that topic but just think about
bequest think about wills wills are
typically go to your spouse to whom
you're not related now that's a puzzle I
mean you can think of some reasons why
that might be but you have to work
pretty hard to reconcile a simple kin
altruism argument what the thing I
studied in South Africa was when
migrants who are working in the mines
send money home to their families they
send vast amounts of money home by the
way can you predict where they're going
to send it by how closely related they
are genetically do the members of the
household to which they are sending it
and the answer is yeah you get a pretty
good prediction except for the fact that
the fact that the spouse is in the
household is far too important for any
possible explanation based on the canal
tourism model so
there's obviously a lot more going on
even within families than the canal
tourism model reciprocal altruism seems
to be a much more robust model because
it doesn't require that the interactions
be among close family members this is
based on repeated interactions and the
basic idea is basically i scratch your
back you scratch mine this works because
the person who helps today expects to be
held tomorrow and lacking this the help
or defects and that punishes the
defector and that enforces the kind of
cooperation now in the the what's with
the the reason why these papers
particularly this one here was thought
to be so well both of them were very
important is because it showed that
reciprocal altruism which I'll use are a
it supports cooperation among egotists
that's the title that Axelrod used in
ensuring in if you have an enduring
relationship which is dyadic that is to
person it really works strongly to
support cooperation in those situation
no matter how selfish the individuals
are however reciprocal altruism fails
when groups are large and x large I mean
three or four not to mention ten or when
information is private known to some but
not to others or noisy sometimes
erroneous or when interactions are not
long-lasting now I want to explain why
this is true that this is an important
point because what happens in the
classroom is somebody takes a two-person
model based on this left for example
Axelrod and Hamilton and they show that
it will work with two people and then
they say well we can extend this to 10
people that's false it can't be extended
even to four people uh it's very
difficult it breaks down and I'll show
you why this is the game which is
usually used this is the prisoner's
dilemma game and it's the opposite of
the invisible hand I call it the
invisible foot for the reasons which
you'll see there are two players and
they choose an action simultaneously
cooperating costs the actors see in
gives be to the other player the payoffs
whether they're in money or fitness or
subjective well-being are shown here and
we have the payoffs here for the rope
layer so that the individual cooperates
and the other guy cooperates they get B
minus C because you paid see but you got
me from the other guy if you both defect
you get 0 if you defect on the guy you
pay nothing but you get B from him so I
think you understand how that works
there are gains to cooperation that is B
minus C is a positive number and that's
better than defecting but they're even
greater gains to defecting on your
partner who's the cooperator now the
reason why this game the prisoner's
dilemma became one of the really
dominant metaphors in the behavioral
sciences in the past half-century
challenging the invisible hand as a
catchy term is because though there is
this benefit from cooperating the
individually maximizing strategy is to
defect so defect maximizes payoffs
whatever the other person is going to do
so it doesn't depend on your belief
about what they do you can see that
right away that B is better than B minus
C and zeros better than minus C so
whatever the other guy does you better
defect it's called in game theory the
dominant strategy now how do we escape
this by repeating the game well it's a
very clever argument uh and it's if the
interaction is ongoing then what's
called a tit-for-tat strategy which I
say to TFT is possible you can first
cooperate and then do whatever your
partner did the previous period if the
interaction is repeated with some
probability delta it will last in
expectations 1 over 1 minus delta
periods that's so it's supposed to
terminate i suppose the the the
probability of continuing delta is is
point 9 well then that interaction on
the average will last for 10 periods so
a tit-for-tat player if he if he's
facing another tit-for-tat player he's
going to get this B minus C 4 1 over 1
minus Delta rounds 10 in my example if
he defected
he would get be but that would be it
he'd get it for one round and zero
thereafter as long as the game went on
so this is the this is the news if Delta
is large enough actually if Delta's
greater than C minus B then both mutual
defect that will always be an
equilibrium but tit-for-tat will be an
equilibrium too so they could end up
both doing this thing here and now the
reason why that's true remember this is
that the tit-for-tat player playing with
another tit-for-tat guy cannot benefit
by defecting because he's thing that it
got just be one time as opposed to
getting B minus C for the whole duration
of the game so this explains why
cooperation could occur it's one of two
possible equilibria it might happen but
of course notice it's not altruistic
because the person who's a tit-for-tat
are playing against another tip for data
is doing this thing which maximizes his
well-being or is in this case his
fitness or pay offs he's not sacrificing
anything now that's why it works and
that's why I was a really exciting idea
beginning with Trevor's and then
developed by Hamilton Axelrod but it
fails in groups this is less widely
known so in the standard two-person game
notice the following if my partner
defects then I know this I know he's
defected with certainty because my
payoffs are low and then if I'd effect
on him I certainly punish him change his
story a little bit make the group a
neighborhood a work group some kind of
organization and greater than two it's
called an end person prisoner's dilemma
game sometimes called a public goods
game in this case the mechanism breaks
down here's why first thing is I may not
know who defected remember if it's just
two people I know for sure the other guy
defected but that's not really the most
serious problem suppose I notice that
somebody defected and I defect in order
to punish him I've also then punished
all of my other comrades who were
cooperating so there's the only way in
this game you can punish the guide
effect it is by essentially just
withdraw
entirely and punishing a large number of
other people who were adhering to the
norm but it gets worse unless they know
why I defected then they'll punish me
because they see me defecting so this
happens often in large groups either I
don't know who defected or I do know who
defected but other people don't know
that I'm defecting because they defected
and as a result cooperation quickly
unravels now I think you can see the
problem in the two in the two person
case my withdrawal of cooperation is a
targeted punishment and here it's not
and as groups get large you're likely to
have a lot of noise in the information
let me show you some simulations that i
did with Herbert gentes my co-author the
what we have here these are these
skyscrapers the height of the skyscraper
is the amount of cooperation that you're
getting this is the size of the group
ranging the these are the dyadic
interactions here we have size 14 and
here's the error rate that's the
probability that a person who intended
to cooperate either didn't cooperate or
was perceived at having failed to
cooperate and this just gives you a
measure of the unraveling process when
the the B is to the benefit is to in the
cost is one and you can see that even
for groups of four if the error rate is
six percent you don't get any
cooperation and four groups of
substantial size you get a lot of
cooperation with zero errors but even
the smallest amount of miss miss of
either mistakes or mistaken perceptions
will cause the thing to unravel but
notice the dyad of course works it's
supposed to work and it does work here
we have a situation where the benefit
cost ratio be over c is for you can see
cooperation does a little better but
here guinness and i were cheating
because we assumed that anytime anybody
defected that was common knowledge so
there wasn't this problem of people
getting punished because they punished
somebody else when when and they were
thought to be an original defector as
opposed to a guy standing up for the
norm look what happens if we
information that's private so here we
have information in which the
information that I have may not be
shared with other people and here you
have basically there's no cooperation at
all I mean even a size of group for
doesn't work and here with the height
with a higher benefit cost ratio if you
get two groups of six or actually for
plausible error rates are actually just
kill it now you think well how do I know
what a plausible error rate is okay
think about the last time you worked in
a coop or in a political organization or
a church and there is some joint
obligation that was supposed to be done
and pretty soon there was some gossip
about whether someone so had done what
they were supposed to do it's really
hard to tell because you don't know well
maybe they really were sick etc so the
idea that you make only six you know six
percent errors error six percent of the
time is I think that's a pretty low
error rate particularly if we're talking
either about today in groups of five or
ten or the past now there are a lot of
other self-interest models it's a real
growth industry particularly among
economists and some biologists there's
um there's something called indirect
reciprocity there is what's called an
economics of folk serum I know it sounds
enticing but trust me you'll be happy
that if I don't explain it the the only
interesting part is why it's called the
folk serum no it's a very interesting
theory but it's very it's actually a
very hard theorem to prove now these
fail for similar reasons that is noisy
information and private information when
you have large groups there is there is
a contender and that's called signaling
suppose I'm suppose I'm a hunter and I
hunt successfully and I bring back meat
and give it away I've just advertised
the fact that I'm a good hunter now
suppose that advertisement is a signal
of some other quality which is not
observable but it correlated with that
so somebody says oh Sam's a good hunter
well he might be a nice guy to have kids
with or he might be a bad guy to get
into a fight with or it might be a good
coalition partner so the basic idea is
you can engage in socially
pro-social activities as a signal of
some trait that makes you a desirable
mate or coalition partner there are
examples of this generosity defense of
the community hunting and distributing
prey I think those models actually
explain a lot about what's going on but
notice these are examples of signaling
and so are these very nice signals of
your ability to make money conspicuous
consumption or if you want to show how
rich you are why don't you just go on
drinking binges that'll show that you
have the capacity to pay for a lot how
about beating up your neighbor that's
just as good as beating up the guys in
the next Valley it demonstrates your
prowess or how about getting a lot of
academic credentials that's also another
form of signaling now I think the
signalling models work I've actually
published stuff about signaling models I
don't think they're a failure but
they're incomplete because they don't
explain why cooperation should be the
result as I say as Thorstein Veblen said
conspicuous consumption does just as
well as defending your community now so
to sum up this segment that somebody may
be looking paradigm as an explanation of
human cooperation as I sake in altruism
is a very good explanation of some
aspects of cooperation within the family
reciprocal altruism works well in dyads
or small groups when information is
public and error-free and the
interaction long-lived but it breaks
down under other conditions noisy
private information large groups now so
the the part of the explanation may not
be that somebody may be looking a part
of the explanation about why people
cooperate is that people actually love
to cooperate they get gratification from
it or they feel ethically that they
ought to do it so I want to explore what
we know about individuals being
self-interested all the time now it took
at least two decades actually beginning
in 1982 a very clever experiments I
didn't design any of these to discover
just how bad a predictor of behavior
self-interest was
now this is interesting because among
economists and biologists the assumption
of self-interest is really very deeply
rooted it's a very useful tool it it
performs an important disciplining
function for theory and it's been
extremely difficult to dislodge that in
in economics and in biology what
happened was a whole bunch of
experiments interestingly a lot of them
done by economists are really sort of
blew the lid off the self-interest
assumptions but i want to say why
experiments because probably if you were
a student in the university now you
probably would have been invited to do
behavioral experiments and you would
have made a little money doing that but
when i was in college we didn't even
know about it now it's commonplace that
everybody that not everybody
self-regarding so but we need to know
more than that I mean sometimes when I'm
when I'm presenting my experimental
results to say sociologist or
anthropologists or for that matter
businessmen they say tell me something I
didn't know I never thought that
everybody was selfish but I insist that
these experiments are extraordinarily
valuable because they tell you
quantitatively how many what types of
non selfish activity they engage in how
do incentives matter if we vary the
incentives what do we get if we vary the
framing of the experiment the kind of
labeling of it what do we get we can do
these things which we can't really do
with self reports I won't go into the
details but we know now that self
reports about do you trust people those
are just about worthless I mean just
about zero correlation with whether
people will loan their bicycle or loan
their CDs or what they do in an
experiment having to do with trust so
experiments allow us to manipulate some
of the things that may affect behavior
while controlling for other compounds
and they also allow us to observe real
decisions made with you almost always
anonymously not entirely almost almost
anonymously and sometimes with with
always with real money on the table and
sometimes with big money on the table so
people are really making decisions about
something which grasp their attention
they're not going to
making it up now there's one a single
experiment as I say really changed how
social scientists think about the
behavioral foundations of economics and
sociology and other fields and that's
called the ultimatum game I have to
explain it to you there are two subjects
it's played anonymously non repeated
so-called one shot game the first player
called the proposer is allocated as sum
of money it's called the pie or the pot
or some other culinary thing like that
and he's instructed to offer a portion
of the amount that he's been given to
the other who's called the responder the
responder knows how much the proposer
got and so he's going to see how much
the guys going to give to him then the
responder can either accept the reject
the offer now the payoffs are as follows
if the responder accepts then she
receives the amount of the offer and the
the proposer receives what what he kept
behind it didn't offer the other hand if
the responder rejects both the responder
and proposer get nothing that's the end
of the game that's all there is ok now
everybody you're all game theorists know
ok and I know that's ok because you
don't really know what it means but I
you're all game theorists and you're all
economists ooh just think about it how
would a game theorists who was an
economist predict that this game would
be played we have a term in economics
it's an ancient one Homo economicus or
economic man how would economic men play
this game so think about it what a game
theorists will tell you is well your
first thing you have to do is you have
to do a fancy thing called backward
induction so the proposer puts himself
in the shoes of the responder and says
what will she do well uh economic man if
she's economic man or economic lady uh
she's going to take any positive offer
because of pennies better than zero well
then I offer her penny and she'll accept
it and so that's the what's called him
game through the equilibrium of that
game on the assumption
the proposer is selfish and the proposer
knows that the other person is also
selfish well I wouldn't be telling you
all this if that's the way it worked out
when this game was first played in
Germany in 1982 the worldwide in over
100 studies mostly with students the
modal offer is 50% that is the proposer
offers half the main offers about 42 and
interestingly offers less than twenty
percent are rejected even when the
stakes are very large and by very large
I mean a month's salary or you know
actually three times that in one of the
experiments in Indonesia so people will
say no they'll turn away large sums now
my interpretation of this there are
others but I think this is this is one
of the things I would have put the
hammer next to I think the most obvious
in parsimonious interpretation is people
are willing to pay big money to penalize
people who treat them badly it's common
throughout the world we've not found a
culture in which it doesn't happen and
it seems to be fairly Universal now I
was very suspicious of the fact that in
in so many different societies in
Beijing in Ljubljana and Tel Aviv and
Pittsburgh the student subjects were
doing the same thing they were turning
down these offers and they were offering
about a half and so on so with a team of
12 anthropologists and five economists
we implemented this game ultimatum game
in 15 small-scale societies I'll show
you where they were in just a minute but
in none of them did the experimental
subjects conform to the self-interest
axiom some of them gave too much the
responders would give you know easily
they give 50 but sometimes they gave 70
in some cases they gave all and the and
as with students in Pittsburgh Tel Aviv
Beijing and so on they they would reject
low offers one or the other or both this
is a paper which is in behavior in brain
science a couple of years ago and that's
that's what we thought we were going to
find when we went around you know we
were looking for these guys like in this
day
painting of love Wars probably we
shouldn't have expected to find him
where we were looking though here's a
group of herders in Kenya we did
experiments with them these are lowland
South Americans these are from New
Guinea and these if you set aside Zurich
Kansas City and what do we have Detroit
over there in Michigan I those are not
we did do experiments there but we were
pre testing the experiments in the field
that's all these ones here now I only
mention a couple of them because the the
point is repeated over and over again
among the h.a in Paraguay we did the
experiment in which a very large number
of people offered half or almost half
and as you can see a lot of people
offered more a few offered less but
these all of these all there's a very
strong tendency for equal division as
indeed there is equal division in other
food items like honey or meet other a
nutrition which is acquired in large
packages and I'm happy to say that one
of the greatest experts on a chase
societies here in the audience tonight
hillie Kaplan is here and I I won't call
upon him to comment on the on these
experiments but he's a professor at UNM
and he's also a professor at the Santa
Fe Institute when we move on to Africa
Tanzania the Hadza we had a rather
different picture the offers were pretty
low I mean notice that's a mean offer
that's not Pittsburgh or Beijing or Tel
Aviv or or Zurich but here we have some
really striking behavior the offers were
low but the rejections were
extraordinarily frequent people rejected
these offers and this is you know this
is a lot of money still twenty percent
of the prize was a lot so people were
turning those things down and this one
imagines that this is also mimicking the
behavior of the Hadza who are famous for
being involved in contestation over
gifts and transfers I actually spent
some time with the hot
and I know a little bit about how they
organize our society they're quite
different from the edge.a but they do
end up sharing a lot but it's usually
through some kind of contestation so
they were pushing the envelope and a lot
of times they were losing their bed by
offering to low and getting turned down
now I want to turn to some recent
experiments with student subjects and
say what I why I think they're important
these are with Swiss students this is a
fantastic experiment done by one of the
guys who I think is one of the leading
figures in this experimental behavioral
economics and behavioral social science
aren't fair and his colleague Simon
Gator fair was also oh sorry I spelled
his name wrong there fe HR fair was also
on the external faculty of the Santa Fe
Institute this is a public goods game
let me explain it to you the idea is
this you have a group of people and you
can put something in to contribute and
anything zero so you're given ten ten
units you can give zero up to 10 the
amount is pooled and then the
experimenter doubles the amount that's
been contributed and distributes it back
to everybody equally okay that is a
prisoner's dilemma with more than two
people because the best thing for you is
to contribute nothing and everybody else
should contribute a lot but whatever
they do you're better off if you
contribute nothing so again the dominant
strategy is zero contribution now they
try to interesting wrinkle here they
said well suppose well here's what
happened they could have contributed 20
that was the total they could contribute
this is the first period of the game it
goes up to 10 periods this is the
average contribution they started out
contributing a little more than six
that's interesting they were why didn't
they contribute zero but they as time
went on they came to contribute almost
zero now they're a lot of speculations
about that what that might be but it's a
kind of unraveling they were trying and
then they noticed some other people
weren't contributing and the only thing
they could do was withdraw their own
contribution and so down it goes that's
the unraveling process I talked about
then here they said okay we're going to
change the rules a little bit these are
all done on computer screens by the way
I said at the end of each round it said
hear hear the people in your group of
course by letter not by name a
contributed this much be contributed
that much and then a sign on the screen
says would you like to pay to reduce the
payoffs of any member of your group we
don't use the word punishment but
there's basically you're going to put
some money down to zap one of the one of
your fellow group members and that's
what happens in these dark dots here two
things you could notice first they
started out a little higher and then
they went up and by the way if you let
them go further they would keep on going
up ah now there's a puzzle here so have
you probably already figured it out
notice is the self-interest predicts
zero contributions but it also
self-interest predicts no punishment why
because punishment is a public good
punishment is doing something gets
costly to benefit the group so there's
no difference between the contribution
paying something to help the group and
punishing somebody at a cost which will
help the group the interesting thing is
that when you allow them when you give
them no punishment it unravels when you
allow them to punish this thing takes
off so this is punishment by peers I
keep this in mind because I'm going to
come back to why this is important and
why it's important for us having a great
future or even if sustainable future in
the third lecture the fact that peer
punishment works is an essential part of
this but notice what we've learned here
is that under the right circumstances
you can get altruistic activity going on
a big scale even in large groups now is
it altruistic yes of course it's L
turistic if the punishment is altruistic
now by the way in a lot of these
excluding in this one the punishments
altruistic because you know that you're
paying money and you don't have to and
it helps the others is the contribution
altruistic think a little bit well if
you contribute you avoid punishment so
you have to actually do the math and
figure out where the punishments large
enough so that the best response in
terms of max
your payoffs was to contribute more the
answer was no so that's an interesting
puzzle getting punished incentivized
people to contribute more but it wasn't
because they made more money it's
probably because they felt ashamed and I
want to come back to that too I want to
get back to the psychology of why it is
that these kind of but the multilateral
cooperation setups really work now I
want to summarize a few of the other
experimental results we know that people
respond to symbolic punishment there's
an experiment done by one of our
colleagues in the 15 small-scale
societies projects in southern Africa
and she did a public goods game just
like fair injector did but she had a
nice wrinkle which is after everybody
had contributed then her assistant went
around and would stand in front of the
chair of the woman who was sitting there
and say mrs. and segundo gave two
shillings out of a total of twenty that
she could have given does anybody have
anything they'd like to say about that
and then you know uproar stingy lady
know what no wonder no one ever comes to
your house you don't get any food and it
went all the way around and then
occasionally some did say mr. gamma gave
a funny and then people would say silly
man wasting money don't you care about
your family and but the interesting
thing about this was notice there's no
monetary effect of this that I had a
huge impact a very large impact so
notice people are responding to
something about the community even when
there's no money a cost to it here's the
third and here's a second result that I
think is really inspiring people punish
people who not only hurt them but people
people who were people other people are
in fact punishment of people who have
harmed a third party is almost as strong
as punishment of people who hurt
yourself the there for example is what
we call third party punishment
experiments so a give some money to be
see
is just an onlooker but after she has
observed what I did then we ask Cici
would you like to reduce your pay off
some to reduce the payoffs of mr. a and
the so and that that's a very strong
result because notice what that says
it's not that I'm angry at the guy who
hurt me of course I am and maybe anger
is also associated with my punishing him
even if he hurts somebody else but we're
getting pretty close to something it
sounds like ethical reasoning because
it's it's it's anonymous it doesn't
matter whether it happened to me or
somebody else it's wrong anyway so the
people who are doing that I probably
have the thing is motivating them is
something which would motivate them also
to uphold social norms they don't do it
equally ethnic and group boundaries
matter this same game the third party
punishment game was done by fair and a
couple of colleagues in Papua New Guinea
with the two tribes were as you know
happened again is a lot of hostility
among tribes with these tribes were not
hostile they were just different and the
but Leon the bystander onlooker whatever
it's called mr. C punished a more if be
the one who got unfairly treated was of
the same tribe as C and if a was not so
in other words ethnic boundaries really
matter in the behavior the and also here
one of my students from South Africa
found that white students in South
Africa expected less reciprocation from
black students and therefore were less
generous to them in what's called a
trust game so the ethnic identity raise
and religion in other cases does make a
difference it by the way it doesn't
always make a difference and there's
some extremely instructive cases which
I'll talk about tomorrow in which it
doesn't appear because we really like to
know the conditions under which that's
not there we'd like to study those try
to replicate them cultures differ
tremendously the the first wave of
experiments said it doesn't matter
whether you're in Beijing or Pittsburgh
the the next way with the experiments
the one in which I was involved said it
matters greatly
if you're among the h.a or the lamellar
ax or somebody else you can range from
giving half or giving more than half to
giving a quarter you can range from very
few rejections to massive rejections
what we found out for example it was a
la mole era who hunt whales and they're
very good at sharing obviously because
they catch these big things only rarely
and they have to learn how to share they
were very good at sharing in these in
these games they gave fairly uh they
gave either fifty percent or greater
they gave on the average fifty eight
percent that is so on the average they
were actually giving away more than half
the institutions matter is an example if
you call the prisoner's dilemma game The
Wall Street game everybody defects if
you call it the community game they
cooperate uh-oh I should have said that
tonight you know it's actually it's it's
kind of rough giving this talk tonight
because the Republicans are now saying
that wall street is greedy and if the
Republicans are calling them greedy how
can I possibly stand here before you and
say the human beings are actually
generous but in any case I think the
labeling of the game has a big part and
saying okay you're in a situation
competition or something in which it's
okay to defect or you're not this is
another one that I that I find this
rather chilling actually if the proposer
was selected by scoring high on a trivia
test so then you know people come in
they take this really it's really a
trivia test and then okay you guys did
really well you get to be the proposers
now notice the proposers are the
advantage ones they're going to get at
least half in America and so you guys
get to the proposers sorry it was a hard
test you guys are the respondents over
here the proposers offer much less if
they were allocated not randomly but by
a trivia test and guess what the
respondents accept these low offers okay
I wish I could go down this road it's
something which disturbs me hugely
because what it means is that a little
trivia test
gives these people a sense of being
deserving or undeserving and that means
I'll accept less or more if one trivia
test does this how do you think going to
school in America works think of the
impact of being in the slow track or
being told that you basically couldn't
do it and that's not just one trivia
test that's 12 years but as I say if I
went down that it would be a different
talk in economics economics did not
welcome these results I think we could
say that in fact I think you would have
gotten instant tenure if you'd found out
something that was wrong with him so if
I mean we really can put a hammer next
to this one because everybody tried to
show that this was wrong now there's
still some confusion because economists
love to talk about rational action it's
a very valuable paradigm I use it myself
but rationality just means that you do
things purposefully and you do them
consistently but economist use the word
rational to mean selfish so it's
important to see our people who are
altruistic actually being irrational
well what would be how do we test that
well one of our faculty members of the
Institute John Miller along with
andreani published a paper in a top
journal in economics econometric ax
which he showed that if you vary the
price of altruism so I can give you a
dollar by paying a dollar or i can give
you three dollars by paying a dollar or
i can give you fifty cents by paying a
dollar that's what they did people
respond to that just the way they would
to the price of ice cream in other words
people's altruism came at a price
they're willing to do it but they
weren't willing to do it if it cost them
a huge sum now why is that important
well first i think that's obvious it
doesn't mean that altruism doesn't exist
it means it's like other things it's
like other things that we like to do or
feel committed to do but we're not going
to do them irrespective of their costs
there's other evidence that people enjoy
cooperating and I think the right way to
see the altruism and so on is of course
we sometimes feel constrained to do
something which we really would not want
to do but we
morally we have to do it and a lot of
great literature could not have been
written if that were true but I think
the vast majority of us are more like
Mother Teresa what they do they get a
great deal of pleasure out of it they do
it because they've internalized those
norms those norms are not constraints on
their behavior those are the reasons for
their behavior their the objectives
themselves they are like Abraham Lincoln
who said when I do good I feel good when
I do bad I feel bad that's my religion
and the only problems that quote is he
maybe didn't say it but if he's no he is
said to have set it right okay I want to
sum up and ask you for your comments and
questions this is alexis de tocqueville
the the most high class tour guide
writer in the world puts puts lonely
planet to shame democracy in America was
exactly that he went around America and
this is one of his conclusions the
Americans are fond of explaining all the
almost all the actions of their lives by
the principle of self-interest rightly
understood in this respect I think they
frequently failed to do themselves
justice in the United States as well as
elsewhere else where people are
sometimes seen to give way to those
disinterested in spontaneous impulses
that are natural to men man but the
Americans seldom admit that they yield
to emotions of this kind the
experimental evidence that i have given
you and the limited reach of the
self-interest models favor talk ville
not Mencken and not Tocqueville's
americans now that leads us to the next
step we have to think about how to react
the question about why humans cooperate
biologists and economists have asked why
does selfish people cooperate or white a
selfish animals cooperate that's
basically that has been the question
that has driven this literature really
for the past 40 years and it's a
fantastic literature and I invite you to
read it I can invite i can email me it's
it's well worth mastering
but I think we've come to the end of the
road with that literature I want to ask
something instead I want to ask how
humans evolve genetically culturally are
most likely a combination of the two to
have the genuinely altruistic
predispositions that account for much of
our distinctive cooperation it's a
completely different question how did we
get to be the kind of people that would
cooperate because we like to cooperate
because we like to help other people or
we feel ethically that it's a good thing
to do now doing this is not uh there's
no hammer here because I'm attempting to
overturn the consensus that this is
impossible it's impossible that we could
have evolved to be that way because by
the very definition of altruism the
altruist would gain fitness by
abandoning altruism and therefore in any
evolutionary dynamic cultural genetic or
whatever which rewards higher payoffs
those altruists would be disadvantaged
so that's a tough order that's what I'm
going to try to do tomorrow but at first
I want to say where I'm going to end on
Thursday evening I'm going to conclude
that those who ignore what Adam Smith in
another great book by the way not the
wealth of nations he called his book the
Moral Sentiments what Adam Smith called
our moral sudden sentiments people who
ignore these policy makers or scientific
disciplines alike are doing a disservice
not only to our science but to the
well-being of humanity as well into our
possibility of having a flourishing and
sustainable future that's what I'll try
to establish on Thursday but definitely
that this is the stuff tomorrow is up
for grabs it's a it's all based on
published research but i have to say
that i don't think i've persuaded
everyone the overturning the consensus
that's going to be hard tomorrow i want
to talk about not the governor of
california
but I want to talk about how altruism
may have become common among humans and
my hypothesis is this Kimmins became the
cooperative species because of our
capacities as institution builders in
biology we would call it niche
constructors constructors of little
environments that worked well for the
cultivated cultivation of altruism and
cooperation and among these institutions
that we were especially good at doing or
things like sharing food with non-kin
and sadly making war I want to also
stress tomorrow and I'll give you some
reasons for hope in this respect that
this legacy of sharing and killing need
not be our destiny that's up to us I'll
make a strong case that that is indeed
our legacy and it even could be our
genetic legacy but that has no bearing
at all on what our destiny is that's up
to us and I'll tell you why I think
that's true and tomorrow will also play
hypothetical history now you can do it
tonight ah and you probably should start
because i'm going to say some rather
demanding things tomorrow you may you
may want to have actually tried this out
yourself don't wait for it to be on TV
when you can run these computer
simulations right off of my webpage I
mean seriously I invite you to do this
if you go to this web page here you'll
find a heading it says artificial
histories it allows you to run histories
that could have happened what I'm
talking about tomorrow is based on 5
million possible histories of humanity
that I have run with my co-authors and
of course we look at them when we figure
out what's what's possible from that you
can do a few tonight if you want it's
really fun it's addictive you have to be
very careful to make sure that you go to
bed at a reasonable hour so if you don't
like what I tell you tomorrow you can
run your own histories and see what you
get now I want to thank my co-author
herb dentist he's on the faculty of the
Santa Fe Institute my co-authors of all
of this work the fantastic staff of the
Santa Fe Institute particularly the
librarians and my assistant Delabar a
mark Margaret Alexander Tim Taylor base
Smith who used to be there
the staff at the Institute makes it all
possible the information technology and
just the spirit of the place can you
imagine where I got the audacity to try
to deal with all these topics I mean you
know you have to face it there's a lot
so I had to start on a lot of new fields
I had to learn a lot of new stuff well I
didn't do it myself I I know that
nobody's door is closed at the Santa Fe
Institute so I bother people a lot I'd
also like to thank the George Cowan
endowment to the behavioral sciences
program that has made this work possible
and other funders this is the Institute
I'm sure you recognize it that's the
University of Siena you'll find most of
these this this is a grouping what we
work in large teams the paper i'm
currently working on has 24 authors
that's that's how we work and these are
some of the papers some of these are
co-authored some are not most of them
are available on my webpage if you can't
find them send me an email do email me
if you want to talk about this I respond
to emails rather quickly and I thank you
all for your attention
talk I'm going to turn it over rather
than me directing I think it's much
easier more sensible to let same respond
directly to the point to those that wish
to make comments or ask questions Sam
please good I yeah I'll recognize you
but you have to recognize okay good i
can see up in the back I thought I
couldn't I yeah I think one other thing
it might be useful Sam for you to repeat
the puppy the question yes I can yes
please in the far back yes you well it's
interesting fictive kin which is what
it's called in the literature is a very
common characteristic of the ways in
which we justify and we rhetorically
advocate the kinds of giving to people
too who are not related to us now that
kind of altruism fictive kin altruism
would not evolve for genetic reasons
because the person who is my fictive kin
is not my relative it is however very
important there I mean very often when
you're sharing goods with somebody you
make them a fictive kin we do that for
example by adoption obviously but you
also do it by for example considering
somebody if you're going to share a
member of your herd with somebody else
very often there's a victim kin
operation but also consider the uses of
the family terms in the trade unions of
many countries members call each other
brother and sister ah that's another
extension of that idea but it doesn't
work genetically it's just a linguistic
way that we have of making it seem like
the stuff that happens at home and it's
one of the great hopes of our species
today in the world that we can start
using whatever rhetorical tricks we can
find to extend to others the things that
we naturally extend to our children and
our parents yes
yeah yeah so I put a monkey wrench in
how
yeah yes there's a es s just me it's the
it's a technical term evolutionarily
stable strategy it means if everybody's
doing it it can't be invaded by somebody
doing something different in that game
the public goods game there is only one
ESS if people are selfish and that is
nobody contribute anything and that's
also the case even if there's punishment
if people are selfish so the only way
you can get people contributing is
because somebody's altruistic at least
somebody I'm not I'm not troubled by the
second scenario but I must have not
communicated clearly yeah way in the
back
well I don't think that would happen
during the Enlightenment in terms of the
things you said it was it was certainly
a brilliant period in the parts of
Europe in European history similar
periods have taken place in other parts
of the world in the China and India the
areas i know best so that there's
nothing particularly unique about that i
will talk about consciousness tomorrow
when i talk about the consciousness of
being different from other people but i
won't talk about the consciousness in
the more broad psychological sense yeah
speak up though because you're going to
have to project by
well unfortunately altruism and smoking
cigars both of which I plead guilty to
or in the past that I dont still smoke
cigars in the past with the scars both
of them would have the same effect which
is they reduce your fitness and this
your question is exactly the
sixty-four-thousand-dollar question that
I'm going to try to address tomorrow how
is it possible that something like
altruism could actually proliferate well
except for the fact that the altars are
doing worse than the other ones and so
they're not going to be any alturas left
that's how genes that I mean natural
selection should eliminate them and that
course the puzzle is I mean you can all
think about how can you solve this
problem probably you can guess how some
of them are but the interesting thing is
that until at least recently biologists
thought that none of them worked none of
them work I think that at least one of
them works that's what I can't talk for
tomorrow yes well if you I said in large
groups of non-kin yes the now there are
some forms of cooperation that do not
appear to be very closely
to genetic relations and genetic
relatedness for example in chimps so
they're I mean they're they're probably
it are some analogues to this and
there's some recent experiment extremely
controversial which suggests that there
may be some forms of reciprocity and
among some primates but I think
basically I think the last 10 years have
not been very favorable towards finding
human like cooperative and altruistic
tendencies in other in other even other
primates now but that is I mean talk
about a restore that's that is a totally
hot topic now and there's some wonderful
experiments being done we'll know a lot
more later yeah in the back there yeah
you
yeah now that that's a very good
question and I'll be able to answer it
better tomorrow but I feel obligated to
answer a little bit you're absolutely
right on in thinking that I'm related to
my kids and I'm related to my parents
and my sibs very closely obviously I may
be related to members of my linguistic
group also but obviously much more
distantly because of hundreds of them
but it might be that the fact that I'm
related to these people in my linguistic
group including strangers more than I am
relating to the people in the other
Valley that could be a crucial fact that
fact is going to come back tomorrow
because it doesn't take much of that to
power a lot of evolutionary force for
altruism so that's we're going to come
back to that inside yeah
i think i'm going to postpone that two
tomorrow because the answer in basically
there is a truth to that it has to been
I'll explain exactly what it is
relatedness is a confusing word because
it could mean kin meaning a recent
common ancestor or it could mean just
people who share more genes with me than
a randomly selected person in the
population that's exactly what i'm doing
tomorrow i'm going to distinguish
between those and show how they both
work yes absolutely
that's it that's enough okay huh i i i i
love your question or questions and let
me start first notice she she she
noticed a discrepancy between my saying
that people played the game the same all
around the world except in my
experiments with Allah malaria and the
people in the Amazon it's on what's
going on here all the other experiments
were done with students and I don't have
a good answer to this but we had
tremendous cultural differences in our
experiments in different parts of the
world which were not with students which
we didn't see when you do it with
students wherever you are now students
have a very similar life they have
similar ambitions they have similar kind
of some things that they have to do they
have to do things like what you're doing
which is to sit quiet while somebody's
giving you a lecture and so on it
doesn't matter where you are that could
be the reason but the fact is very clear
we deliberately picked societies which
had is little in common with each other
as possible in that meant not exposed to
the same modernizing forces like states
and markets and what we found was very
interesting we found a lot of
differences so that's true now here's
here's an interesting criticism of the
fraternity of people who do these
experiments most of these experiments
for most of the time that they've been
hot which is about two decades now have
been aimed at showing that economics is
wrong though they've been done by
economics they've been aimed at showing
something about human nature in general
so there it's called essentialism so in
philosophy they wanted to figure out
what humans were like and they wanted to
say we're not like Homo economicus we're
like homo something else oh by the way
that's when I got the restaurant is
easily word homo economicus all the time
and it said you were using a rude term
honest to god it did so I so so the
problem is we were designing experiments
to find out under which conditions
people were and weren't selfish we were
not asking the very good question that
you were asking which is well there's a
differ by social class by educational
level but we've you know by chance we
found out a fair
out I'll give you just a few things one
is accidentally we found out that
African Americans are much more justice
minded than European Americans that's
not a big surprise perhaps they give
exactly fifty percent offers and they
reject anything below fifty percent with
very high probability we've also found
that in some areas of generosity the
farther down you are in terms of income
and so on because we're now doing these
with truck stops in the Midwest people
have a lot of time so we do these we do
these in factories and so well you don't
you have to take a little rest you've
already talked to the wife and so you
get a game going and you know and you
get people who are not students and yeah
we're finding out they're different now
are these differences caused by the
social structural things you said I'm
convinced they are I'm but I have to
admit to I was convinced that they are
before the experiments because I read a
lot of history and anthropology and it
just seems perfectly reasonable that
people who grow up catching whales are
going to have a different set of values
and norms and ways of behaving that
people who grow up say doing industrial
work or maybe provisioning themselves by
catching small animals and other things
now what do I know about that now well
we know a lot about how your economic
circumstances has a big impact on the
kinds of values that you have some of
the work is reasonably old but the work
that we did about the lamb elara for
example one of the things we did we took
these 15 societies and we said let's
ranked him according to how valuable it
would be in that ecology to cooperate so
very valuable if you're catching whales
not very valuable if you're doing slash
and burn agriculture or some
horticulturist very low technology
horticulture and that what we found was
that the places which we're relying on
their cooperation in order to survive
well sure enough they were very fair in
the ultimatum game and the places the
other places tended to be much lower so
we're getting some information now of an
experimental nature that allows us to
say that yes the values that people have
are formed by their everyday experiences
and it will be a long time
before we have it really well understood
but and if you want to know more about
this this happens to be something I'm
working on uh yeah yes well they didn't
know the subjects were inside the
machine but yeah yeah definitely I i if
I'd had more time that's one of the
reasons by the way why I think that
people enjoy cooperating you do an
ultimatum game and the subject is inside
the thing and then he hears what offer
has been given him right and then he can
either press the button accept or reject
and by the way leave the fMRI is a
non-invasive brain scan that actually
takes slices of your brain and it looks
at the activation of the blood
activation therefore the oxygen
activation of particular areas we think
we know something about which areas do
what that's by the way we don't know as
much as we should but we're pretty sure
that some areas have to do with the
processing of rewards while other areas
have to do with the processing of more
cognitive things balancing costs and
benefits so we find out what's going on
when somebody says no to a bad offer uh
and guess what we found out well I
didn't i dint do these studies but
they're a bunch of them now being done
ernst fair some of the big people the
big guys doing these ultimatum games all
now have fMRI machines and the the
rejection of offers gives a sense of
pleasure in the sense that it's
processed in the part of the brain that
processes other things that are
rewarding and the receiving of a bad
offer is experienced as discussed the
author of that study said that is the
areas which are activated are the same
areas that are activated if you're shown
a plate of rotten food now isn't that
interesting that we could have evolved
to have a sense at a brain that works
according to something like moral
discussed it would be maybe fitness
enhancing it may lower your fitness if
you rotten food and it also may lower
your fitness if you don't stand up for
justice but the fact that the same part
of the brain is processing that is
suggestive now I happen to be in the
school
all that thinks that these
interpretations of fMRI experiments so
far have gone way beyond the the
empirical base base of these it's
because the samples are extremely small
it's extremely hard to know what it
means to say this area is being
activated and so on so is just a warning
you'll find a lot of stuff being
published which is making big claims I
think it's going to be 10 years from now
a very interesting window into some
aspects of why people are doing this but
we're not there yet yeah that's exactly
Thursday's talk that's I I not only have
I thought about that that's mostly what
I'm thinking about now because that's
obviously where I've been led to having
established so far what we've got okay
here we are we're in a dangerous world
which we are making more dangerous all
the time what can we do about it maybe
the Constitution for knaves has failed
maybe we have to try something else I'll
tell you what I think yeah
mm-hmm say more about that what would
what yeah but what's what's the
connection between the commonality
yeah well that is a great question and
it's it's a very interesting hypothesis
i am convinced i'm convinced both
because I know something about genetics
and human development but also because
I've lived a lot of my life in Africa
and India I'm convinced that we're all
very similar but what would make you
discussed it is not what would make
somebody else disgusted even when it
comes to food like in our country we
think that blue cheese smells good well
have you ever thought about it
objectively it smells like a lot of
other things that we don't smell bad
right but i think the exactly the same
analogy would hold food discussed and
moral discussed might be very very
different across cultures but i think
you're onto something when you're
thinking that it might be that moral
discussed a visceral reaction against
unfairness and injustice might in fact
be something that's common to all people
if it's true we're very lucky but then
again we have to find ways of
adjudicating between the competing
claims about what is unjust and what is
not but the fact that people may have a
sense of justice deeply ingrained
culturally of course but also possibly
genetically I think that's very good
news for Humanity okay I think that's a
great place to stop humana joy right
where else to end to the more nights
that's right Sam
thank you great